paris ville morte ou presque
les nouvelles règles de confinement
porte ombrage à la ville lumière
olga croyait bien que son petit
restaurant du quartier latin pourrait
traverser les deux prochaines semaines
d'interdiction de circuler certes avec
un peu de pertes mais la stupéfiante
nouvelle réalité l'a vite rattrapé par
reset restait on n'a jamais vu ça court
même pendant quand on les entend on n'a
jamais vu ça les fermetures obligatoire
explique pourtant les commerces
alimentaires mais encore faut-il des
clients les boulangeries qui n'ont pas
éteint les fourneaux demeure source de
réconfort pour les français qui perdent
aujourd'hui un peu tous leurs repères
moi ce que j'espère c'est que ça va
rapprocher les gens
là on nous promet solidarité tout temps
j'espère que ça va marcher
la cure donné pour acheter le pain du
jour proche avec les syndicats ou à
l'ouverture de certains supermarchés ce
matin quelques heures avant l'entrée en
vigueur des nouvelles restrictions de
mouvement à la gare de lyon à paris on
se dépêchaient de quitter la ville avant
l'heure fatidique
il y partage et la nervosité de grease
est sa chatte qui a peu l'habitude des
voyages
voilà ce que j'ai pas envie de tout seul
sur paris d'autres y était plutôt par de
voir sa mise et riou fait partie de ceux
dont la présence au travail est
essentiel gendarmes
il doit se rendre près de la frontière
italienne pour faire respecter
l'application des nouvelles mesures
ça peut dire la guerre entre tout le
monde puisque tout le monde a peur tout
le monde
les mythes légendes c'est la bonne chose
qu'il faut faire je pense pour éviter
encore plus de soucis vis-à-vis tout
seul depuis midi donc tous les français
qui circulent dans la rue doivent
nécessairement avoir vécu cette
attestation de déplacement dérogatoires
qui justifie le motif de ce déplacement
cent mille policiers et gendarmes se
sont déployés dans toute la france pour
effectuer des contrôles
beaucoup étaient déjà préparés hugo
n'avait pas de quoi imprimer il a rédigé
sa note à la main on a le choix entre
plusieurs justificatifs mais moi c'est
pour motif familial puisque mes parents
sont divorcés donc je vais chez mon père
a tué ma mère
pour françois les policiers se sont
montré tolérant pour donner du temps aux
nouvelles habitudes d'être intégrés on
faisait dans la pédagogie plutôt que
dans les constats d'infraction et dans
les amendes les activités en plein air
en solo reste autorisée mais dès demain
autrement se retrouver dans la rue sans
motif pourrait être accompagnée d'une
facture salée ici marie ève bédard à
radio canada